previously on seven days to die
did you make it all bloodbaths yeah
this is our home now this is a nice
place to hold out
in oh hold on don't mock
me do not mock me there's a blunderbuss
down there if you want it
i hope you choke on it i hope you choke
on it
eat this honey i'm putting it in the
chest here mark you look awfully tasty
no honey honey this is going to take a
while guys in case you're
wondering just get a hand hammer your
way into a safe
yes i am a man with
five blunderbushes i got hit once by a
vulture and it immediately infected me
dude come on man i can't help it i'm
very susceptible
oh no let me reload all my blunder bye
no that's not good
yeah i've i've also got a bit of a
problem here am i the only one at the
house
i'm well yeah i'm climbing onto a roof i
i don't know if i can get back to the
house or not
i just want to say again how i was all
like
hey we don't have any defenses
if we don't have the defenses how could
we possibly survive
i found a way onto a roof i'm actually
on a roof all i have to do is
is keep them out of my hole if you know
what i mean no i don't
oh my gosh i'm actually safe safe
i'm gonna just i'm gonna wait out here
mark you'll probably be fine
i will be fine because i have six
blunderby
but wade the poor sop my life force is
draining
come to me why are you outside of the
house hey
they were breaking in what do you want
me to do let him break in open the door
time it i don't know do something just
make your survival chances
stamina is a problem for me i think
dying is bad for me
hey mark can i have some honey you're
starting to look tasty again oh my god
it's inside how do you get infected so
quickly wait i don't know i don't know
is it i think it's just a random chance
i think i just have really [ __ ] luck
we have a we have a food situation yep
i've got four foods i don't want to hear
a
single peep out of your face i don't
want anything
out of your face it's like you guys
want to make me mad i don't know why
i'm sorry is there an echo in here are
you done you're done
not even at all and i think you know
that
i'm sticking to just one of the
blunderbie if you guys want another
blunderby it's up there
also i now know how to make eggs and
bacon hey
do the the i got a recipe
what what did you do the [ __ ] what
wait you do the family friendly
did you do the hardcore graphical sex
yes and you know it hey i'm at the house
guys i'm gonna put all this random crap
i have in this empty cabinet so i don't
have to carry it around
i had two chests there oh okay i put
those down there for us
they're by the campfire what'd you do to
the chest you made up
nets did you just again ejaculate
all of your inventory into the chests
yes i have two chests and there was kind
of a system which test did you ejaculate
upon
oh you'll know it when you see it i'm
trying to i'm trying to discern the
system
there's only two there was only two so
it was like junk kind of in the
left one and then important things in
the right but you know
whatever who who actually cares you
could just take this and heal up a
little bit it sucks could you just
laugh a little bit
well i can't even do the voice look at
this guy
can't even heal up a little bit oh
you're in my house
what are these mines are these landmines
guys if you hear a loud kaboom they were
land mines
i'm okay good so not landmines oh
still not hundred percent on the not
land mine part but
so far so good i'm thirsty
i'm assuming 27 boiled waters my dudes
wow
i don't like that bob mock his sound
that he made
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody look she's naked i'm sorry oh god
they're very naked i'm gonna throw my
spirit this
if it kabooms my spear is gone
i'm gonna shoot this if i die
kill me oh
i thought that would have done more to
the wall
hmm that doesn't make sense for a
landmine only the way you crossed your
legs that's cute
are you talking about the naked packer
definitely need that
what about what nothing you worry me
sometimes wait you worry me a lot
bob are you hearing this no
i don't know if you get to decide what
bob hears
yes all right i guess he did not hear it
then
all right why am i why am i tiny i'm
mark's height oh i was scratching
i i'm sorry i don't mean to use these
really confused
completely
no you know what i'm not gonna engage
with you
i'm not gonna engage with you oh growl
growl growl who the [ __ ] has that
or who the hell who the heck you've
really
changed man you've really changed i just
gotta say that
you've really changed well you used to
never say a single curse word and now
like you i i can't even believe you i
used to have
aspirations of being like pre-law and
stuff now i know that dreams are just
for losing
i hate to break to you but lawyers swear
a lot
no they're angels
yes actually you're right is anyone
gonna do like the whole
you know defenses you know i am working
on it
anyone anyone gonna get this i am
working on it
would anyone in the world please
hello yes i'm working on it all right
19 repair kits oh
uncle no hey uncle la
la la la i love uncle i love uncle
oh [ __ ] you bird oh i will [ __ ] your day
oh my god please family friendly if i
could
bang it the nice way no i figured out
what
it's doing what does he do mark always
records these and then post them on his
own channels
if we just swear constantly he can't do
that
it's reserving the content for ourselves
and there is gameplay
you're right you're right you're right
you know what you're right how are you
going to come back this
mark uh well or should i say
oh mark i found a bunch of
blunderbusting ammo do you need some uh
i'm not gonna say no but i'm not gonna
say yes
level five there was an air drop to my
southwest a long
long time ago and quite far away yeah
why don't you go there wade and never
come back
got him oh who put just all this junk in
this
valuables one who put a pine cone in
here
why dude you know what pine cones turn
into
that's a whole tree in one tiny little
package you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right i need a gun i find all
this [ __ ] but no guns
i don't think you know what
blunderbusses are well a decent gun
look they changed the loot until we
level up we can't get it
i'm got lucky motor out my rear it
doesn't matter
where do i buy my ar-15 i don't know
if you've got coins you can go to the
trader we are not near the trader
there's a trader 500 meters away i don't
see it says 0.0 meters for me i don't
see a trader did someone leave the fire
on oh are you making stuff
no i'm not making stuff it's just on oh
well that's not responsible
i'm not responsible i cancelled your
cooking
but for a reason before you get upset
with me what bob
i don't believe that was real have you
guys ever sneezed so hard your arm goes
numb
that's not good all right so again about
the whole defenses thing that we don't
have
i have 41 uh spike trap thingies
all right why do i hear enemies already
outside yeah what's happening
what's going on oh my god uh we're being
attacked by a mini horde
go great good all right
all right well done gank all right good
job guys
how is my how's my ass
amazing incredible outstanding actually
why am i so hungry is there a way to
pick up spike traps once i place them or
is that just a mistake you can't unbone
it's forever above you well you couldn't
before
i don't think forever boned uh it's uh
it's time o'clock oh [ __ ] wait why don't
you run
into the house because i don't want the
[ __ ] breaking in and ruining our
home oh god oh man having trouble
closing that
out
baby oh boy what do we got there
blunderbuss ammo
oh hey sorry jeez
should call for opening i guess all
right i'm gonna open
do it are you me and opening
all right oh no oh oh it's still up it's
still up and still up
okay oh the other one's almost through
i'm tearing the door repairing the door
dark in here oh there's a zombie in here
that's way i'm getting hurt
wade where are you back door all right
where are they coming in also where
where else are they coming in they're
coming in somewhere else
where oh you're all right wade
oh yeah i feel great all right i'll put
it in the door
boom what you need more honey
why you can't get back you must be
uniquely susceptible to getting
infected it does seem like i've got a
pretty [ __ ] immune system in this game
your hygiene is just subpar all right we
seem to be good
oh wait nope i hear one yep there's two
over here that have almost broken
through
go around to the west side of the house
on the outside you might be able to take
some by surprise
nice so this is just gonna keep getting
worse guys
yeah so like if we could like i'm
working on the defenses okay
okay i'm just saying i'm just saying i'm
just saying
i think exploring is the right move
right now okay
oh bob what level is your x uh level one
here doesn't you can't recraft a level
three but if you keep repairing this one
it'll be a better axe for you
can i get a better ax can i get it
no i think i can actually craft like a
level 2x
yeah you can give mark a level two
actually what about me
with level three i would like one
here really good axe on the ground
oh well i but i don't need a level two i
already have well it's a level one you
gave me bob you must have mistaken me
you guys have any honey wait no wait
wait i've gave you two pieces of honey
how
like you owe me you owe me you owe me i
guess i
do have this all right
thank you i don't have any honey though
so you're on your own
i feel kind of betrayed right now you
got two pizzas before
you shouldn't have squandered it later
nerd
thanks for the x nerd why is
right click place i hate this so much
you want to move no i just i keep
placing when i think i'm
rotating because a right click is place
because
why i think i am going to try and build
the
upstairs though although i really need
like a whole [ __ ] ton of wood
what is happening to me said a bird the
gusher
get wrecked
anyway what dysentery better digestion
what's gonna cure my turning into a
zombie wanting to eat my friends
a bullet don't mark homie just saying
that's
usually the cure man this tower would be
super defensible
it's got a lot of staircases that we
could just lay traps down then we could
get like a ladder to go up the side
interesting very nice very near to our
other base too you know
and in the city more so we could you
know just go in and get what we want
and then go interesting interesting yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty cool
pretty cool yeah why am i so hot what
the hell temperature is it in this place
it's hot temp all right thanks for the
contribution to this conversation wait
you're welcome
keep trying keep trying buddy you'll get
there
ass
is that helpful okay uh yeah huh why am
i so hungry and thirsty what is wrong
with me eat drink
no one's getting food i sort of said i
was gonna get food and then i sort of
didn't get food
i'll go with foreign i'm never gonna be
able to pick this lock
maybe you should just give up did you
put points in the left oh
no of course not why would i do that
when i could
axe it
it's gonna take forever what's wrong
babe
no did i break a window to get into a
place that
right to one window down was god i'm an
idiot did you say words in that
was it are you that kid from that meme
who can't talk so
good yes ah
guys i'm afraid i might be mark slow
guys listen everybody at home reading
donors
is like a bird you know sometimes they
swoop in
and catch it all the time you pick out a
sweet little donut
[Music]
this has not gone well for me dudes
i have nothing i'm going into this fast
food restaurant and i hope there's food
wait the air package i'm gonna go get
the air package
i have a new purpose in life i have no
stamina i'm so thirsty i have to go into
the restaurant
it's raining outside get some get some
air water even though that makes perfect
sense that's not how this game works
it's raining and i'm still hot i don't
like this yeah the
heat the heatometer could be better in
this game you need heat protection
you're in the desert
oh you guys don't look as tasty this is
great whatever man
is this traitor below ground
yeah that's the one i had it does look
like it you know
what i just wanted something to drink
and these jerk-offs
these real wankers
they're giving me the business oh
perfect yes yes yes give me
oh soda fountain yes because i oh mega
crush
baby guys you ever had mega crush
no but i wanna you want mega crush mega
crush is dope you get 50
run speed oh hey one of the devs is here
what's up well the devs is here
you might be playing a19 on an a18 world
no we just started this one this is new
yeah i i
i pre-gender i did a random generated
world uh just before we started today
yeah
what's okay dev what's more likely that
your game isn't bugged or that we're
idiots
what do you think is more likely okay
all right cool good get back to me on
that one
mark there's there's a big consensus as
to which one of those is true
i feel bad for the developer then
listen it's okay you've only had seven
years
to get the game right no traitors
underground
we'll forgive you a little longer
right wade uh yeah
it is still an alpha after all
[Laughter]
what's a few bugs oh i found they i
found the uh airdrop
ah there's med kits there's a level five
sledgehammer which i know you guys were
really hopping for
uh there's level four boots
antibiotics say you love me wade
tell me you love me baby love you baby
thanks say what you'll do for me if i
give you these
antibiotics oh i found some i don't need
yours okay
this uh military base doesn't seem to
have an entrance that's not so good
wait no i walked all the way around it
oh hey i found some honey too
great i'll burn you why after my heart's
been broken
yeah oh
all right anyway i am so hungry
why is food so hard to find i found some
food i've killed one snake
i've found food i'm not
well we are in like the deserty hot
biome we need to find a forest i think
more animals
generally spawn in the forest biomes as
if you would know would you know i've
been playing
this game since like 2013. haven't
played this game since 2013.
nice nice nice yeah i did it right yeah
yeah yeah yeah no
bob does when mark does it's just kind
of like yeah okay yeah yeah sure yeah
act like it didn't hurt
what in the water now hey the water
cools me down whoa
wait he's like you're trying to haunt me
i found food but i don't know how much i
can bring back i i don't have much
inventory space
oh interesting i'm just going deeper
into this place
uh i may be too deep and i may not be
able to get out and then i'll die with
all my food with me
oh my god this place is like a whole
underground facility i don't even know
what all this is
oh did you find one of the cool like
labs against technical [ __ ]
i did yeah but there's there's a locked
like vault door that i can't get by and
i don't have enough time to break it
yeah well you can parkour around it
at least there is okay i found it i'm
not going to go too much because it's 20
and i need to get out of here
well you also have a cut-off time soon
too don't you oh is it already home oh
my god it is
oh no well we'll survive this night
together my bros
together like ohana means family it
means family
and family means poopies in front of
each other
well that too obviously how how would
you not have that
but additionally no one gets left behind
all right i'm coming home guys oh
stamina i'm encumbered
i have all this food i'm laden with food
i'm not gonna make it back guys
good god no that's not good you don't
say good to that
no no i'm about to be left behind you
guys got to help me
no stamina no stamina if you don't have
any stamina there's nothing i can do for
you what do you mean there's nothing you
can do for me what are you gonna leave
me behind
good luck no don't good luck me you were
a good friend
while behind you oh you guys all right
seems like none of that
it actually seems like none of them are
trying to get me
seems like all of them are trying to get
you and not none of them are trying to
get me there's some trying to get me oh
there's a bird too
why is there a bird oh no no no no no
no no no i missed how could i miss your
own point
wait if you could right here there's a
ladder right here
jump and then climb it and then come up
on the roof and we'll be fine
help wait you're not coming up on the
roof
help oh how did that miss
wait can you please come up on the roof
okay there there is
please wade seems dead
faster than a steak plate in front of
myself help
how do i get to the roof tell me now
i'll listen to your instructions bob uh
directly under me there's a there's a
ladder on the wall where all the
where all the bad guys are oh are you
here i'm almost there
why i can come down and help you no no
no
no no no no oh my god please no one
health
i'm bringing you your food bob
come to the roof sir i'm trying it's for
some reason i got suddenly slow where's
this ladder where's his ladder
where ladder right underneath me it's on
the wall jump up
what that's not you those are enemies
yes
yeah the house is gone the house is gone
no
i'm fine just come on the roof where's
this ladder i'm literally on top of it
oh is it there's no inside i am on top
of it is it accessible from the inside
yes it's inside oh i didn't know why
would i put a ladder on the outside
i don't know so i can get to it ah
get out of my way they're in the middle
you didn't say they were inside you did
not say they were inside where's his
ladder
what he did say that where's the ladder
where's the ladder
where inside help you you're so slow
where is the ladder it doesn't matter
i'm dead now
how are you jesus why are you dead oh
because they're all on the roof
oh that that the roof was never safe i
see
the room was safe except i kept opening
the door to try and find you
dumb [ __ ] ah that doesn't seem like
us
to find a ladder and climb it it's pitch
black
there's zombies all over the house i
just died
in two seconds because you built it you
built it you would know
all right we're good and easy
you are morons hey
where's his ladder where is his letter
oh i
see it i see okay all right okay
the pitch black there's no way there's
no way i saw where it was
before it was sworn but i could not take
two steps toward it i climbed up and
down the ladder
several times after you had been moaning
about it
hey hey hey here you want food thanks
i got you thanks thanks i got you i feel
much better after dying oh i bruised my
knee
why am i so weak you bruise your knee is
that actually an ailment in the game
uh bumps and bruises are the most common
type of injury heal over time
perks or medical items like aloe cream
first aid benches or first aid kits can
increase the healing speed
man you're really pathetic man oh i have
a mining helmet
i had a flashlight on my helmet the
whole time
oh you're lucky i'm out of uh one
ow is that what you're gonna do why
would you do that oh would you do that
don't you would miss oh my god
that's right in there all right
hang on buddy hang on let's see all
right now i
do you if my spears disappear hang
on oh mine went right through you yeah
hang on i got one more i'm gonna go
center mass
here yeah and it disappeared
huh why can't i impale you but you can't
impale me
because your game is broken and you
bugged it out you
cheating cheater
all right also everything we did there
doesn't matter i have to start a whole
new game next time we play
[Music]
bye